ahora que sabemos un poco más sobre la
integral de convolución y cómo se aplica
la transformada de laplace vamos a
tratar de resolver una ecuación
diferencial usando este método así que
tengo esta ecuación con valores
iniciales la segunda derivada de y más
dos por la primera derivada de y más dos
porque que es igual a seno de al fateh
y nos dan las siguientes condiciones
iniciales
de cero es igual a cero
y prima de 0 es igual a 0 lo que es
bastante bueno porque estas dos
condiciones harán que este problema sea
mucho más sencillo y entremos en materia
lo primero que hay que hacer es
encontrar la transformada de la plaza de
ambos lados de esta expresión la
transformada de la plaza de la segunda
derivada de g va a ser ese cuadrada de
hecho esto ya debe ser muy familiar para
ustedes ese cuadrado
por la transformada de laplace de g
de ese que le escribo como ya y
mayúscula
- s recordamos que tomamos el mismo
grado de la derivada que estamos
trabajando y vamos reduciendo ese grado
conforme vamos a agregar los términos a
esta y lo multiplicamos por ye de cero y
ahora vamos a tener menos seguimos
incrementando la s por lo que ahora
vamos a tener que prima de 0 la s fue
elevada a la 0 y eso era transformada de
la plaza la segunda derivada y ahora
vamos a encontrar la transformada de la
plaza de esta y prima que va a ser igual
a más 2 por la derivada de prima s por
jbs
esa es la derivada menos de de 0 y ahora
solo nos queda una la transformada de la
plaza de 12
que es igual a más 2 por la transformada
de la plaza que es de s
y esto tiene que ser igual a la
transformada de la planta el seno de al
fateh y ese tipo de transformadas las
hemos hecho un sinnúmero de veces hasta
el momento esto es alfa / s cuadrada +
alfa al cuadrado
lo siguiente que hay que hacer es
separar los términos de la transformada
de la plastia y los deje y ahora vamos a
deshacernos de esas condiciones
iniciales por lo que este término este
término y este término son cero así que
nuestra expresión total y ahora puede
escribirla todo en un solo color nos va
a quedar
es al cuadrado
porque de ese más 2 s jbs
+ 2 de bs
que es igual a alfa
alfa entre ese cuadrado más alfa al
cuadrado
ahora vamos a factorizar la aie de s que
es la transformada de la plaza de y nos
queda ese cuadrado más 2 s más 2 todo
esto está x
jbs que es igual a esta parte de acá
alfa / s cuadrada más alfa al cuadrado y
ahora podemos dividir ambos lados de
esta ecuación entre esta parte de cada
esta escuadra damas 12 c + 2 y nos queda
llévese la transformada de la plaza de g
que es igual a alfa entre s cuadrada más
alfa al cuadrado
x el inverso de esto 1 entre ese
cuadrado más 12 c + 2
y bueno ya que tenemos esto esas
fracciones así que es lo que tenemos que
hacer vamos a resolver esto en el
contexto de la convulsión y estoy
buscando una transformada de laplace que
luzca como una multiplicación de
transformadas de la plaza conozco cuál
es la transforma de inversa de la plaza
de esto así que lo que necesito es
encontrar cuál es la transformada
inversa de la plaza de esta parte de acá
y así expresar el dt como una integral
de convolución incluso aunque no
necesariamente resolvamos la integral a
partir de ahí es sólo el uso del cálculo
y aunque fuera una integral que no
pudiéramos resolver podríamos usar una
computadora o algo así pero bueno vamos
a tratar de dejar esto en términos de
una integral de convolución que puedo
hacer con esto este no es un cuadrado
perfecto así que lo siguiente es tratar
de completar el cuadrado perfecto aquí
vamos a reescribir esto
como ese cuadrada +12 ese más algo más 2
si lo escribimos así si yo escribiera
ese cuadrada más 2 s 1 esto sería un
cuadrado perfecto pero no puedo agregar
un 1 así como si voy a agregar algo
también lo tengo que quitar para
mantener la equivalencia así que aquí
tengo un -1 noten que aquí no he
cambiado nada se mantiene exactamente
igual pero esto ahora lo puedo
reescribir
como ese 1 al cuadrado
y esto se convierte en un +1 esta
operación acá
por lo que puedo reescribir cdc como
igual a alfa / s cuadrada más alfa al
cuadrado
uno entre todo esto
ese es uno al cuadrado más uno
y ya dijimos que sabemos cuál es la
transformada inversa de laplace de esta
parte
de esto de acá conozca cuál es su
transformada inversa ahora tengo que
encontrar cuál es la transformada
inversa de esta otra parte esto que voy
a encuadrar en un bonito color azul
y ahora necesito expresar esto en una
forma integral de convolución como luego
vamos a hacerlo en este momento vamos a
escribirlo decimos que lleve t
la transformada inversa de gds es igual
a la transformada inversa de la plaza de
gds lo escribimos de ese que es igual a
la transformada inversa de la plaza de
estas dos cosas
alfa / s cuadrada más al cuadrado
multiplicado
por 1 entre ese 1 al cuadrado más 1
y ahora el teorema de la convulsión nos
dice que esto va a ser igual a que va a
ser igual a la transformada inversa de
la plaza de este primer término del
producto la transforma de inversa de la
plaza de alfa entre s cuadrada más alfa
al cuadrado convolución nada con en
convolución nuestra estrella se
significa aquí con la transforma de
inversa de la plaza de este otro terminó
en convolución con la transformada
inversa de la plaza
transformada inversa de la plaza de 1 /
s más 1 al cuadrado más 1 cuando tengo
el producto de 2 transformadas inversas
de la plaza puedo tomar cada una de
ellas de manera independiente y la
transformada inversa de la plaza del
producto va a ser la conducción de las
transformadas inversas de la plaza de
cada de cada factor o de cada uno de los
términos bueno creo que lo que dije
hasta a mí me confundió pero creo que
tienen la idea
reconozco estas dos cosas de manera
independiente y tomo independientemente
la transformada inversa de laplace de
cada una así que la transforma de
inversa de la plaza de sus productos van
a ser la colusión de cada una de esas
transformadas inversas ahora qué es esto
de aquí bueno esto es lo que vimos en el
principio del problema la transformada
inversa de la plaza esto es seno de alfa
por te iba ahora vamos a convulsionar
esto con la transforma de inversas de
laplace de este otro término y para
encontrar la transformada inversa de la
plaza
este término tenemos que hacer algunas
anotaciones a un lado para no
equivocarnos la transformada de la plaza
de seno dt es igual a 1 / s cuadrada más
1 y esto es muy parecido a esto pero
está desplazado está desplazado por
menos sólo ustedes pueden acordarse que
la transformada de la plaza de a a la
aporte por seno de t
cuando se multiplica
elevado a la aporte por cualquier otra
cosa lo que se va a hacer es desplazar
la transformada de la plaza 1 / s menos
al cuadrado más 1 y ahora tenemos esto
desplazado por a
si dijéramos que nuestra es igual a
menos 1
nuestra a igual a menos 1 entonces
tendríamos exactamente este patrón de
acá ese menos menos uno sería ese más 1
al cuadrado más 1 así que la transforma
de inversa de laplace de todo esto es
a la que queramos que es menos 1 - usted
por celos de t
se lo dt y esta es la solución a nuestro
problema a nuestra ecuación diferencial
aunque no es un resultado muy elegante y
si quisiéramos podríamos expresar esto
como una integral pero no voy a resolver
la integral en este vídeo pero si lo
hiciera pues sólo tendríamos que usar el
cálculo integral para resolverlo o
quizás alguna computadora veamos esto es
igual aquí vamos a hacer la convulsión
de estas dos funciones
la integral de 0 a t
de seno nuestra primera función de t
menos estado no hemos visto esto pero
podemos intercambiar los términos aquí
dentro en este se no vamos a escribir de
esta manera
celo
d
de estado
todo esto multiplicado por alfa y todo
esto es el seno
x ha lamentado seno de tao
de tal esta es una manera de expresar la
solución de esto como integral de
ecuaciones diferenciales y esto les debe
aparecer a usted es obvio que puede ser
en cualquier dirección porque cuando
tenemos un producto aquí no importa en
qué orden estén los factores el orden no
importa así que puedo escribir este
término primero o este otro término
primero se aplica el mismo principio y
esto lo voy a demostrar en un vídeo en
el futuro
así que otra forma en la que pudimos
haber escrito esto es
a la menos usted se lo de té
cómo evoluciona do con celo de alfa
porte y esto hubiera sido igual o es
igual a la integral de cervantes
a la menos de menos estado
por el seno de este estado
multiplicado por el celo de alza
aportado de tal
así que estas son equivalentes
cualquiera de estas respuestas es una
respuesta aceptable si por ejemplo las
tuvieran que responder en un examen y de
hecho ningún profesor esperaría que
ustedes se evaluarán estas integrales al
menos en un examen sencillamente les
interesaría saber que ustedes saben
hacer convulsiones defunciones y
encontrar una solución en términos de
una integral de convolución
espero que esto les haya aclarado
cualquier duda con respecto a este tema
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo